magari ci avviciniamo inesorabilmente e
inevitabilmente all'episodio numero 200
di f siamo al 100 96 e tantissimo ne
mancano quattro compreso questo prima
dell'episodio sociali ricordatevi che
sia al 100 99 che il duecentesimo
saranno molto molto speciali quindi
arriviamo straniera swing l'udc era un
passato fatto crollare
partiamo il primo sono anche io
ultimamente ho sviluppato la capacità di
non saper parlare nei video è molto
importante soprattutto dopo che fai lo
youtuber da 20mila anni sto ricredendo
meglio e lo più prova all'inizio
l'importante è giocare è più v6
divertirsi questo lo dirò anche a 65
anni qualche problema tired forever and
one perfetto il possible 99,300 che
questo mi sembra anche abbastanza
tranquillo soprattutto per il fatto che
gli impossible sono livelli che ormai un
anno gusto sono i club a farci non c'è
queste sono visti tutorial tentativo
solo se mi riusciva potevo concludere
qua il video di ringraziare il cielo che
non è riuscito avrei fatto un salto dal
balcone dalla gioia miasmi sono vantato
per poi fare farlo sul serio
guardo toccato lo tocca lo sto toccando
ho vinto e anche se è evidente non me lo
stai dando ma ho vinto il piede c'è è
facile per niente ma sembra ragazza
prego
ma ha leccato il traguardo del care il
traguardo sinonimo di vita l'ho fatto
anch'essi mcqueen di saetta mcqueen di
steve e quindi è un attore c'entra
niente
andiamo avanti a minecraft quiz dove
avete fi to go wine ott certo ma perché
non dovresti farlo parola perché non
facciamo un quiz sulla regina elisabetta
poso luigi xiv
ci siamo quando è stato rilasciato
minecraft credo nel 2009 quando ancora
aveva 10 anni
ok chi ha creato minecraft epic games o
markus persson incredibilmente difficile
è bello che di storia non fa niente per
questo non so chi è stato il primo
minecraft speedliner di tutto di tutto
il tempo stavo dicendo traduzione
italiana perfetta fifi voti fi perfetto
non lo sapevo non avevo idea non avevo
idea rifacciamo ragazzi alla speed run
sarebbe fini del gioco il meno tempo
possibile però mai appoggiato randomico
come fai a preciso lispida non di mike
non sapevo comunque gravissimo nitricum
non sapevo facesse anche il
videogiocatore quali di questi minerali
è uno dei più vari nel gioco iron lo
smeraldo credo smeraldo sia più del line
anche perché quando io quando ho
iniziato a giocare a minecraft agazzi
non c'era la metà della non c'erano il
cibo non c'era cioè c'era il cibo per
due però la vita ma non c'erano le
bistecche per recuperare la vita cioè
non c'era la bistecca non potevi correre
nel 2009 il make up si può dato al bene
non esiste una corsa gennaro i cream
alimentata solo dopo anche nella realtà
si potrà correre grazie alla nike che ha
inventato le scarpe o in casi finale
reit no il nat logan in tenchio prego
that's ok poltrona ottagono di niente
tensione sdl e cioè in 57 minuti 25
secondo in difficoltà media si devo
andare su unlock e uil
quindi non devo fare così perfetto non
ho capito se ci hai messo 57 minuti per
fare livello ma io ce la metterò molti
di meno zio allora devo andare sul blu
parte che la vittoria non la vedo la
vittoria con la verde che chiusa
perfetto non prenderò mai con questa
palla si sa lo aspettate a grosso però
ce l'ho ce l'ho ce l'ho ce l'ho
orco demonio è difficilissimo è uno dei
ball troppo difficili che abbia mai
fatto perché devi incassa perfetto della
cassata ragazzi scherza guardalo che e
professionalità se leggere il [ __ ]
che sfiga allucinante è lì non era
facile però attenzione proprio lui il
campione mondiale di happy meal
olimpiadi prop singhbhum cioè nel senso
parliamo di animali hanno blu voler
iscrivere auto blu goro coni mi avrà e
porco qui e poi cala e porco oppure il
mio fra credo che tutto questo possa
funzionare dal momento in cui non mi sta
con le braccia perché i ragazzi negli
rock swing se mi stacco ma c'era una
bottiglia o sbaglio è cascata una
bottiglia senza un motivo in tutto ciò
va bene cosa mi rappresenta e cascato
pure il casco fa niente iolo prevede un
test herat 5 nel mezzo
[Musica]
molto bene 98,9 perbene che fa si
calcoli che descrive le percentuali di
limbo c'è qualcuno pagato per farlo a
mano a mano su un grazie lo prende la
moneta non prendo la volontà manifestata
sopra a sinistra
però voglio anche provare inserito a
vincerlo dall'altra parte ci siamo solo
per testare non è questo incidente fa
niente se non ci riesco ragazzi
importante esserci riusciti in una delle
sue maniere ma sono sulla vita che non
esplosa 1 sono morto
oddio e stretching e 1 e 2 e 3
attenzione ti potresti anche buttare
se avessi voglia di farlo dall'altra
parte dovresti buttarti c'è l'azione che
difesa un sacco ok se tu riesci a
buttare non di là non di la nave va bene
non fa niente a guardarla conto come una
vittoria mi va benissimo perché c'è il
testo di an vergogna ghini o up nella
descrizione di un rock swing
margone che chiuda
dice eccomi a trigger ato rickroll sono
forse solo perché non avrei fatto questo
livello
sembra che ha fatto molto bene e quello
che mi destabilizza la vita ho perso il
braccio ragazzi nei libri le braccia
sono necessarie né rock swing senza non
posso vincere però attenzione
cosa vi dico era un troll alla fine l'ha
giustamente neri crono per forza stai
partire per garantirlo però non lo
possiamo fare perché c'è il copyright
nino lo facciamo perché grafica soggetto
proprio lui proprio lui a velocità
massima morto
che ci faccio ci parla che non la parte
di sotto l'importante nei questi livelli
e non avere la parte di sotto qualcuno
l'ha detto a sta cosa nella citazione
car thieves car of thieves euro giocati
così of thieves solo che sparì coi
cannoni dalle macchine credo un bel
livello comunque in profondo v6
impastato è più ma questo è successo ma
dai
ho schiacciato un livello a questo
livello questo livello blu non gli altri
questo livello blu madonna è difficile
vado a sto caricando crysis è il remake
uncharted 5 sto caricando della stoffa
sul parte iii cosa sarà mai suo livello
all'ex lamenti auto blu in auto blu di
simeri facebook stifani coca cola and
mento se cambiamo livello ragazzi perché
quella è veramente difficile da caricare
porco demonio cosa sta succedendo è più
il abbiamo rotto happy with signori ha
caricato effettivamente ce l'abbiamo
fatta solo di forlan non ti preoccupare
il 2 ore che carico finisce qua a
sinistra si può passare a sinistra forse
si può andare attenzione più incredibile
mi aspetto una morte per una volta era
veramente così ma le ragazze new è fatto
serio ovviamente ma che finora ho una
freccia in testa sempre indossare il
casco ragazzi lo dico io che vedi
funziona questo non era veramente così
difficile porca vacca l'ho fatto subito
diamond diamanti
spiegami
faccio un attimo un ufficio sto
scherzando da e tnt diamante art
a nokia devo prendere i diamanti devo
schivare ok ok hard vai subito felice ma
niente 2 co demonio 3 e non ho la spinta
necessaria non ce l'ho oh mio dio 7 ott
beh dai 8 su 12 non è male aiuto 9 9 su
12 secondi ce la posso fare a farne di
più aspetto che ci riprovo poi ragazzi
sono un fenomeno se riescono mai provato
già subito in hard è veramente sapere
già dove andare e poi parole che sono
non puoi bello no maledizione 8 tutorie
roberto stato bravissimo ce la faccio
ragazza fosse lui a mano che faccio 12
non impegniamo così tanto manca scuola
incredibile è che c'è una latenza di
movimento sto [ __ ] coso che il
comando da anni che non sai come si
chiama ok libero che una festa che non
gli ho mai dato non appare però ti rendi
conto che a quello non ci puoi arrivare
cioè la tnt che anche questo non ci può
arrivare le tmt scendono troppo prima 10
su d'orba quei due non li puoi prendere
ma neanche per sbaglio 6 ori questo era
è più visti oggi ne vale in realtà
perché pensavo si potesse andare molto
peggio ma colpi che ne deduco che dopo
200 episodi quasi 200 io sia skillato
tal punto da finirli quasi tutti quindi
ragazzi i propri video sia piaciuto di
schede v al canale come al solito e noi
ci vediamo
bella ragazza
[Musica]